welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
Brian vachmeyer more than six years
after police started investigating that
70 show star Danny Masterson a jury who
found the actor guilty of forcible rape
Masterson was handcuffed inside a Los
Angeles courtroom as his wife who has
stood by his side for the entire
investigation gasped and soft Masterson
was first tried last fall when jurors
couldn't come to an agreement about what
happened in the actors Hollywood Hills
home between 2001 and 2003. that's where
multiple victims claim Masterson drugged
and raped them prosecutors vowed to
bring charges a second time and a
retrial got underway in the spring this
time around the judge allowed the
witnesses to say they were drought
despite known forensic evidence of drugs
being presented and the Church of
Scientology featured more heavily in the
retrial it took the jury seven days of
deliberation to reach their decision
Masterson has been free on bail since he
was first charged but will now be locked
up until his sentencing that date has
not been announced yet but a post-trial
hearing is planned for August
Massachusetts users are also suing him
and the church in civil court
the jury in this second trial did a
major flip-flop from the first trial
basically coming to the opposite
conclusions when the jury was pulled
following the mistrial this was the
breakdown two jurors voted to convict on
count one with ten saying not guilty on
count two four jurors voted to convict
and the third count had the most in
favor of a guilty verdict but still only
just five of The Twelve in the retrial
the jury convicted on two of the three
counts and voted eight to four in favor
of conviction on the Third Rate charge
one of the women whose accusations led
to Masterson's guilty verdict released a
statement Wednesday she said I am
experiencing a complex array of emotions
relief exhaustion strength sadness
knowing that my abuser Danny Masterson
will face accountability for his
criminal Behavior
the charge connected to Masterson's
ex-girlfriend led to a jury deadlock she
said in a statement while I'm encouraged
that Danny Masterson will face some
criminal punishment I am devastated that
he has dodged criminal accountability
for his heinous conduct against me
I'm joined Now by my co-host former
trial Attorney Terry Austin and today's
special guest former Federal prosecutor
Mima Romani Terry the jury did not
convict Masterson of rape in connection
with his longtime ex-girlfriend why do
you think they came to that conclusion
and what are your thoughts about the
vote count in this second trial well I
think it's interesting the fact that in
the first trial they had so many
acquittal votes and in the second trial
they had more people who were voting
guilty and in fact obviously two of
those counts they received conviction so
I think the evidence that went in in the
second trial had a big difference and it
certainly was some of that drug evidence
some of the evidence as far as
Scientology I think they did not convict
as far as the ex-girlfriend which is
that third count because I think she had
been with him and they had some
questions as to whether or not that
actually was sexual assault yeah Nema
the judge allowed evidence about drugs
during the second trial but not during
the first a bit of a change there could
that'd be a legitimate ground for an
appeal
it could be Brian but I think the Judge
made the right decision ultimately any
witness can testify and establish any
fact you don't need corroborating
evidence you don't need a blood test you
don't need a medical report to say that
you were drugged if you believe that
you're uninfluenced of drugs and that
laid witness can lay the foundation
that's enough so obviously we know
Masterson's lawyers are going to appeal
we should get that notice of appeal any
day now but it's going to judge make the
right decision and I expect this verdict
to stand on the field yeah I'm going to
be interested to see what their
arguments are and how that appeal is
either denied or granted will of course
follow the story for you the one-time
game show contestant charged with his
wife's brutal murder is facing a
potential life sentence after a jury
took only four hours to determine his
guilt
guilty of Home invading signed by the
poor person in 11 years
being held without bond until his
sentencing in August evidence during the
trials showed Becky bleepnic was
becoming more and more scared of her
husband Tim as the two went through a
bitter divorce she believed he wouldn't
do anything to get sole custody of their
three sons the prosecution says belief
Nick broke into his wife's home and shot
her 14 times the jury agreed Becky
believes Nick's sister gave a statement
after the verdict
we should not have to suffer a life
without Becky
Becky was robbed of her life
in the most hateful
cowardly and cruel way
her boys were robbed of a loving and
devoted mother
I was robbed
of my sister
and best friend
my parents were robbed of their daughter
and as a parent myself
I cannot imagine a greater torture the
judicial process cannot bring her back
nor can it heal our wounds
but we are relieved that the verdict
delivers Justice
and we are thankful for all who made it
a reality
welcome back to Long crime daily our
coverage of the jury's decision in actor
Danny Masterson's rape trial continues
prosecutor security conviction their
second time around the first trial ended
in a mistrial on all charges but on
Wednesday 12 jurors found Masters and
guilty on two counts of rape they cannot
raise your decision on a third count
which was connected to Masterson's
ex-girlfriend Masterson and her his
accusers were all members of the Church
of Scientology during the retrial the
judge allowed a church policy to play a
larger role with a former official even
testifying about church policy but other
Witnesses testify that current church
members had intimidated them trying to
convince them not to testify or to lie
the Church of Scientology released a
statement after the verdict saying in
part the church has no policy
prohibiting or discouraging members from
reporting criminal conduct of anyone
scientologists or not to law enforcement
quite the opposite church policy
explicitly demands scientologists abide
by laws of the land
we caught up with Tony Ortega a reporter
who has covered the church for decades
to get his take on the impact from The
Trial
there was a lot more Scientology content
uh during this retrial and there's just
no question Scientology looked terrible
in this thing I mean Danny Masterson had
received protection from the church
these women had been punished for being
victims which was you know right in line
with the way Scientology thinks about
those kind of things these women were
told they should not go to the police I
know Scientology has put out a statement
saying that's all lies but it's right
there in black and white in their book
telling members that they can't go to
Civil Authorities that they have to keep
things inside so you know I think the
although Scientology was not technically
a party in this criminal case
this was a disaster for the Church of
Scientology I've talked to literally
hundreds of ex-scientologists and they
all will tell you that that's where they
were trained that everything is to be
kept in-house with the scientology's own
Justice procedures
uh this is not something that you know
it just came up lately I mean this is
something that's that's Bedrock a
Bedrock principle of Scientology and I
know that they claim it's not true
but Scientology lies I mean it's just
one of the key features of the
leadership of Scientology you will not
get the truth from them
Church of Scientology PR team is working
overtime Nima the judge said that the
Scientology church or the church
Scientology sorry was not on trial in
this case but do you think it played a
large role in the outcome
it did Brian and although technically
they weren't on trial it was a huge
issue here and really the defense opened
the door they said that there was no
contemporaneous report this was all
fabricated and of course that allowed
the prosecution to argue that it was the
church that covered all this up and
discouraged these victims from coming
forward that's why all that evidence
came in and it was a terrible look for
the church they tried to litigate
prevent this evidence from coming in and
they were unsuccessful and I think
ultimately one of the biggest losers
here aside from Danny Masterson of
course was the Church of Scientology
yeah we'll see how that goes for them
Terry several Masters accusers have
filed a lawsuit against him and the
Church of Scientology what's going on
with that you know that's right Brian
now there is this civil lawsuit and they
shoot Masterson but they also sued the
Church of Scientology and they sued its
leader so this is a big case they're
saying that there was my favorite cause
of action intentional infliction of
emotional distress and it's been filed
since a couple of years ago so 2019 it's
in Cal California and they've asked for
a jury and they are asking for
unspecified damages so because the
church is involved I think they have an
opportunity here to have a big win and
all of the plaintiffs include the
plaintiffs or the individuals who were
in the criminal trial and also it
includes the husband of one of those
accusers so there are a lot of
plaintiffs a lot of defendants I think
it's going to take some time to go
through the system but I think at the
end of the day we're going to see
probably a judgment in high numbers that
is your favorite claim I got to find my
favorite criminal charge I'll work on it
another Hollywood actor will not face
charges of sexual assault after an
investigation by Los Angeles police Army
Hammer who gained Fame in movies like
The Social Network and call me by your
name says he's glad his name has been
cleared in 2021 a woman accused Hammer
of raping her in 2017. Hammer maintained
that any sexual contact would have been
consensual but the accusation prompt
investigation the District Attorney's
Office released a statement saying they
were unable to prove the case Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt because of insufficient
evidence